You're Mr. Osanai from the mail news, aren't you? My
first impression was g 3
graffiti If you team up with me, you'll be the top in Tokyo right
away I don't ask for anything in return I'll
get it myself
[music]
I know myself I
'm alone in the moon  I can't shine
[music]
That's what happened when I met
you I didn't like it All the guys I didn't like came from me And
I didn't want someone to buy harm Then before
I knew it, there was no one around
me  It's good
that the other party was a plain flower
Strangely enough, everything went well when I listened to what she said
So,
you,
who are not a colonel, were able to become early in the morning at Mobius because you had a predecessor
?  I was just a stepping stone for him
.